yeah i wanted to ask you michael about
uh let's talk about what's going on with
russia and ukraine obviously you were
born in ukraine uh-huh
uh and i guess yeah yeah i'm just
curious what your thoughts are what's
going on you know russia said they were
gonna shut off here's the big news
russia threatened to shut off gas to
europe unless they opened bank accounts
that would hold their currency us
dollars in euro which would then do in
exchange for rubles
and april first came and putin did
nothing like
a whiny little [ __ ]
he
he failed to uphold his own threat
against these nations so i'm curious you
know your thoughts on what's happening
i've been asked this more than anyone
this is probably the question i get
asked a lot and like people blowing on
my phone um and i pride myself on trying
to have an interesting perspective or at
least say something uninteresting in an
interesting way and i got nothing on
russia ukraine for the very simple
reason that i don't understand putin's
endgame
i don't understand how he thought this
was going to end up that i can tell you
that anyone who just says he's stupid or
he's crazy that just means they don't
know either they're just using this kind
of word to kind of
kind of do the work i just i just
assumed you knew that um the the spear
of destiny has been buried in
the holy land
um so putin going for the spear of
destiny i i raised like five grand for
uh ukrainian refugees my dad was
recently he had business in ukraine he
was on a train getting out of there and
he was sitting next to some kid and the
kid kept crying saying they're gonna
kill my dad they're going to kill my dad
my i heard this through my sister and my
dad who i've never seen cry in my life
who is kind of which is a big surprise
looking me a
kind of an ass um and not a very nice
person just like myself for him to lose
it really says a lot which is why i was
comfortable raising all that money um
what is not in dispute is that millions
of people fled war understandably
and my concerns are also with the
russian population mind you like the
fact that someone's living in russia now
they can't use their phone or they can't
use uh some bank account just seems
crazy to me unless it's talked about
yeah but but look at what russia is back
on track
well yeah and the ruble has restored
value they turned mcdonald's they turned
the m like sideways to make it a b and
now it's called like uncle something
yeah yeah yeah they they've repurposed
what joe biden has done
is he severed the ties between russia
and the west
these restaurants still exist right the
russian supply chain still exists so
putin basically is like going to
industry and saying get what you can
that's why putin threatened europe he
said you've got to open russian bank
accounts it it's forcing western nations
to open russian banks propping up their
financial industry or their financial
sector my
as you and i mentioned a little before
the show started i
what they're doing is an enormous attack
on the value of the dollar
whether by design or otherwise and
if i'm a businessman and i see what
happened with canada with the trucker
convoy and i see what's happening with
with inflation here and i see that my
money is not going to be safe in u.s or
western banks i'm going to put my money
elsewhere to make sure that money
retains or increases in value and that
is a very dangerous slippery slope we
are going down whether by design or
otherwise well you heard the the
blackrock guy saying put your seatbelts
on it's going to get real bad inflation
but i think we all knew because one of
the things that we all talked about in
like 20
early 2020 mid 2020 is you can't just
shut down all industry yeah and not have
an economic like massive consequence
like that's not a thing or else every so
often we could just be like school
teachers just not work for three months
a year so at some point those chickens
are gonna have to come home to roost
this is not in dispute no one doubted
that so you've gotta you've gotta find
places to put your dollars
what what does the average person do
right i mean if you're living paycheck
to paycheck it's gonna be like venezuela
get your money and spend it immediately
on whatever you can i would honestly i'm
not gonna this is gonna sound like a
joke but i would put in crypto i think
crypto is gonna be a much better store
of value in the short term let alone the
long term i think than the us i think
crypto is what the world economic forum
is hoping for you think so you think
absolutely digital currency no they no
i'm not their digital currency i mean
things like bitcoin or ethereum i know
yeah i know they're they're stoked on it
they're very excited for it bitcoin will
be their gold and they'll use ethereum
is on the is on the is on the amazon web
services right aws i don't know is it
theorem ethereum is basically a company
right
so uh bitcoin is decentralized that's
resilient but what uh
i think the the the the elite the the
world.com davos group types they're
they're betting on this you don't think
crypto is a better store of value than
the us dollar oh it absolutely is oh
that's all i'm saying yeah no when when
when klaus schwab and these
international corporations are betting
on bitcoin you bet along with them right
yeah you you here's here's here's what
people are doing to make money they look
where nancy pelosi is investing and they
invest right along with her yeah because
she's got an inside track right
i i told this uh before i don't think i
don't know if you know this but i went
to davos and i think it was 2017. i have
friends who set up a peripheral event
outside of the world economic forum at
like the base of the mountain or
whatever in davos the whole city becomes
events
pop-ups and bars and crypto was the
theme everyone there was like crypto
crypto is everything
so i bought i bought a bunch crypto and
i'm very happy that i did i think i
think uh
these elites
they want digital currency
bitcoins trackable they can they can see
everything you're doing you know and uh
so it's perfect for them they they they
can ban you they can shut down your
account they can ban addresses if i've
got cash i can pull out you know a five
dollar bill and hand it to ian in
exchange for a beanie or something but
if we're doing bitcoin my address can
get blocked on the network
if they control transactions so the
bitcoin
let me clarify this
if they can get control of apps if they
can get control of financial
institutions there are companies that
facilitate bitcoin transactions sure
you'll always be able to have your like
rudimentary decentralized service and
you can find an open source way to
transfer bitcoin but for the average
person look you can hide you can put
stacks of cash under your mattress or
you can put it in bank of america you
put in bank of america the government
can can take your money from you so
that's what they want it gives them
substantially more control you'll be
less likely to be holding any kind of
cash you won't be
so no one's going to no one right now
no average person is going to open up a
coinbase account and an open source
third-party wallet because it's going to
be too confusing for them they're not
going to care if they are into crypto
it's going to be because it was
simplified by say coinbase or gemini or
something sure and the government can
easily seize all that stuff so it gives
them more control it's like we saw when
they tried to do that thing where they
were going to track ultra all accounts
that had 600 bucks or more in
transactions right yeah this is the path
forward for them that being said despite
all that
yeah i i bought a bunch of crypto
recently but i also think that this is a
huge market incentive to provide wallets
that are as easy to use as coinbase
because once this becomes like for
example apple a couple years ago made it
so that even apple couldn't get into
their own uh iphones because uh as
because then they were like if we leave
a back door for law enforcement that's a
backdoor for hackers too it's got to be
open source yeah i agree with you so so
i think but don't you think the bitcoin
people know this
yes they're the kings of open source
stuff yeah we were looking at uh crypto
payment systems metamask is not open
source at the moment which is a little
disturbing and that means any company
can have the government go to them issue
a national security letter then you're
gone and you wouldn't know like that's
the problem with when the source isn't
open you don't know what their code is
doing it could be feeding data to the
fbi as we speak coinbase could be very
well and you wouldn't know
i'm sure they are i would be surprised
to put it again but they are bitcoin is
still
you know the bee's knees right
regardless of what bad people want to do
with it don't let that that stop you
from recognizing how powerful it is
and how it can greatly you know help
people but also
i'm not telling anybody to buy anything
keep that in mind guys no financial
advice for me i'm just saying
don't you know do your own research and
figure out what makes sense for you in
my personal opinion for me i bought up
on what point can the cops institute
civil asset forfeiture if you like what
level of cash do you have to have on you
before they can just take it from you
it's not a level of cash is think is
even a dollar it's just it's just a
measure of them deciding that it was
used in the drug transaction
and not only that but like let's be real
ian they can take your shirt off your
back and then lie about it
that's so brutal but i mean legally
legally they could take
my money and be like he's we thought he
was planning on spending it on something
illegal so
or he got this money because he sold
drugs you see that story about a woman a
dog
sniffed her out she had a bunch of money
in a briefcase she had like what did she
have like a hundred grand or something
and then the cops were like smiling
saying like we took this money from a
woman and everyone was like i tweeted
this i was like so you're saying you
just rob some lady yeah and everybody
was like yo they said she didn't commit
any crimes they just took her money they
those are the only dogs you're allowed
to hate
dogs yeah
but can they take the money and say
we're just taking it because we think
you're going to commit it oh no they
have to save you
so this is how asset forfeiture works
and there's a lot of movement right now
in politics thank god to reign this in
uh for the first time i think in the
last year of the year before more money
was seized through asset forfeiture than
through all burglaries combined so
basically it goes to this medieval
concept where if i kill you with a sword
the sword is guilty and the sword can be
destroyed this is like a thing so
basically what their point is well we're
not going to allow as part of the drug
war people to enrich themselves through
drug uh um dealing and so on and so
forth so i go to your house i've decided
that you're a drug dealer so on and so
forth i seize all of your assets your
boat your house your your i seize your
um
uh bank accounts and they become
basically the property the cops and this
and then you have to sue although you
have not gone through due process and
been found guilty to get that stuff back
now it's really hard to sue when all
your money is spent and all your assets
have been taken from you
okay so that is kind of the situation
and it's really un-american and
unconscionable and it's kind of
surprising how much it's under the rug
yeah really it's so disturbing very very
disturbing and i gotta tell you if
someone is a drug dealer as which
something i do not support to have like
every penny that they have just take it
from them overnight seems a bit much
when that's not done to murderers or
people who harm children yeah
non-violent drug offense man let's talk
about it this is the i think jerry
nadler just has been pushing forth
legislation thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there